>>> FOR THE FIRST TIME IN HIS
LEGENDARY CAREER, LeBRON JAMES
FACES ELIMINATION IN THE FIRST
ROUND.
WELCOME TO THE LeBRON-A-THON
LIVE IN THE BLEACHER REPORT APP.
MY NAME IS CABBIE RICHARDS.
VOLUNTEERING HER MENISCUS FOR
THE PROCESS IS ERIN DOLAN.
A MAN NOT AFRAID TO TAKE A BOW
AT CENTER COURT AFTER
ELIMINATING YOUR FAVORITE TEAM,
THAT'S GREG IVORY.
I KNOW YOU HAVE SOMETHING
SPECIAL FOR OUR AUDIENCE TODAY.
WHAT HAVE YOU GOT FOR US?
>> WE GOT THE HOODIES AS USUAL.
I DON'T HAVE THE HANDY DANDY
iPAD, BUT I HAVE THE LITTLE
COUSIN, THE HANDY DANDY iPHONE.
I HAVE IT RIGHT HERE.
I'LL GET IN THE COMMENTS AND
GIVE AWAY A HOODIE.
WHY NOT.
I HAVE BAY LEGEND IN THE
COMMENTS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
JABESKI DUER IS SAYING LeBRON
JAMES WILL GO OVER HIS POINT
TOTAL TODAY.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I ALSO HAVE NBA JERSEYS TO GIVE
OUT.
WE'LL HOOK YOU UP WITH $125 TO
PICK OUT WHATEVER JERSEY YOU
WANT.
I WILL GIVE IT AWAY LATER.
ACTUALLY, I'LL GIVE IT AWAY NOW.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS GIVING AWAY
TO 125 WHO IS COMMENTING.
I GOT ALEXA LONZO.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
SHE GAVE US THE THEME OF LeBRON
JAMES AND J.R. SMITH.
THERE IT IS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERS
JERSEY.
ERIN, I HAVE THREE MORE TO GIVE
OUT TONIGHT.
WHAT JERSEY ARE YOU BUYING?
>> I WOULD HAVE TO GO WITH THE
PHILADELPHIA 76ers, THE CREAM
ONE.
THE ONE THAT SAYS PHILADELPHIA
IN CURSIVE.
I NEVER ENDED UP GETTING IT
BECAUSE YOU COULDN'T GO TO THE
GAMES.
NOW THAT YOU CAN GO INSIDE WELLS
FARGO, I WANT THE CREAM JERSEY.
>> ARE WE GETTING JERSEYS?
ARE YOU SPREADING THE LOVE TO
ERIN AND I OR JUST FAR THE
AUDIENCE?
IF YOU'RE GIVING THEM TO US, YOU
PUT ME ON TO SUNSET VIBES ABOUT
SIX OR SEVEN MONTHS AGO.
GIVE ME THE DENVER NUGGETS,
SUNSET CITY EDITION.
JAMAL MURRAY.
THAT RED JERSEY.
GIVE ME THAT ONE.
AND WILL WE GET THEM?
>> YEAH.
I DON'T SEE WHY NOT.
>> YOU DON'T SOUND TOO SURE.
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THIS IS RIGHT
HERE?
CHECK THIS OUT.
WHAT IS THIS?
IT'S AN AMERICAN EXPRESS CARD,
BUDDY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT.
>> WHEATEVER YOU WANT.
WHATEVER YOU WANT.
IF I HAD TO CHOOSE A JERSEY --
>> YEAH.
>> HEY, CABBIE, IF I HAD TO
CHOOSE A JERSEY, I'M TAKING IT
TO THE BAY, MAN.
I'M NOT GOING WITH KLAY OR THE
LIGHT-SKIN ASSASSINS, I'M GOING
WITH BIG DRAY.
DRAYMOND GREEN.
>> THE JERSEY HE'S WEARING RIGHT
NOW IS THE SUIT ON "INSIDE THE
NBA."
>> DOING A GOOD JOB.
>> DOING A GREAT JOB.
ON THE OPPOSITE SIDE OF DOING A
GREAT JOB, THE PANIC BUTTON HAS
BEEN HIT IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES CAUSING A COUPLE OF
MINOR EARTHQUAKES.
BOTH THE LAKERS AND THE CLIPPERS
ARE ON THE BRINK OF ELIMINATION
TONIGHT.
THERE ARE TWO GAME SIXES,
PORTLAND AND DENVER, PHOENIX AND
L.A.
WE ASKED YOU ON TWITTER, WILL
LeBRON JAMES AND THE LAKERS BE
ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
IT'S AS SIMPLE AS THAT.
GAME SIX.
AMERICA IS VOTING.
58% YES.
THEY'RE RIDING WITH THE SUNS.
CP3, WE ALL SAW WHAT HAPPENED IN
GAME FIVE.
THE HOMEY, EL CAPTAIN HIT A BIG
TICKET BY CALLING THE BLOWOUT.
THIS IS ELITE LEVEL HERE.
>> OH.
>> BRON SAID IT AFTER THE GAME,
THEY GOT THEIR BUTTS KICKED.
THE 30-POINT HALFTIME PLAYOFF
DEFICIT WAS THE LARGEST IN
LeBRON JAMES CAREER AND THE
SECOND LARGEST IN LAKERS
HISTORY.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME EVER FOR
LeBRON HE'S BEEN BEHIND IN A
SERIES AFTER FIVE GAMES IN THE
FIRST ROUND.
SO, LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
MAJOR MARKETS, ERIN DOLAN.
WHAT HAVE YOU GOT FOR US?
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING ON THE BOARD
THAT YOU LIKE?
>> ON THE FANDUEL SPORTS BOOK,
THE LAKERS MINUS 3, BET DOWN TO
MINUS 2, NOW 2 1/2.
IN TERMS OF THAT TOTAL, BOTH
TEAMS HAVE BEEN TRENDING TOWARDS
THE UNDER.
THE UNDER HIT 4-1 IN THE LAST
FIVE GAMES.
WANTED TO NOTE, 207 1/2 THE
CURRENT TOTAL ON THE FANDUEL
SPORTS BOOK IS THE LOWEST LINE
SO FAR SET BETWEEN THESE TWO
TEAMS IN THE SERIES.
>> THAT'S THE MEN Y
MENU.
G. MONEY, WHERE IS THE AUDIENCE
LANDING?
>> LET ME GET IN THE COMMENTS
AND ASK.
EVERYBODY WATCHING, GET IN THE
COMMENTS.
TELL ME WHETHER OR NOT YOU THINK
LeBRON IS GETTING ELIMINATED
TONIGHT.
TELL ME -- ALSO TELL ME IF YOU
THINK HE'S EVER WINNING ANOTHER
CHAMPIONSHIP BECAUSE I
PERSONALLY DON'T THINK HE IS.
>> WHAT?
>> ERIN -- I DON'T.
>> THAT'S BLASPHEMY.
>> UNLESS HE'S GETTING A STEPH
CURRY OR --
>> GETTING UP THERE.
>> YEAH.
HE'S GETTING UP THERE IN AGE.
>> HE'S STILL TOP FIVE OR TOP
TEN.
LET'S NOT BLAST THE KING.
YOU'RE NOT USUALLY A HOT TAKE
GUY, BUT YOU KNOW LeBRON IS A
SHADOW GM.
YOU KNOW EVERY TIME HE'S PLAYING
ANOTHER TEAM, HE'S -- I DON'T
WANT TO SAY HE'S ASPIRING, BUT
HE HAS A LOT OF RELATIONSHIPS.
>> HE'S GETTING UP THERE IN AGE.
THAT'S THE ONLY REASON.
ERIN, I HAVE TO KNOW, IS LeBRON
JAMES GOING OUT TONIGHT FOR
GOOD?
ARE THE LAKERS GETTING
ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
>> SEE, I'M SO TORN ON THIS.
LAST GAME I WAS HYPING UP
LeBRON, I WAS SAYING HE WILL BE
THAT VINTAGE LeBRON, STEAL THE
SHOW.
OBVIOUSLY I WAS COMPLETELY
WRONG.
IF A.D. DOES PLAY TONIGHT, HE'S
A GAME-TIME DECISION, IF DENNIS
SCHRODER REMEMBERS, HE NEEDS TO
SCORE.
LAST GAME HE HAD ZERO POINTS.
THERE IS HOPE FOR THE LAKERS TO
FORCE GAME SEVEN.
I WOULD NOT BE SURPRISED IF THEY
COULDN'T DO THIS, EVEN ON THEIR
HOME COURT.
THE LAKERS TO WIN THIS SERIES
RIGHT NOW, PLUS 225.
I'LL TAKE LeBRON TO BE
ELIMINATED RIGHT NOW PLUS MONEY
SINCE WE DON'T KNOW THE STATUS
OF A.D. FOR THIS GAME.
>> IS THAT WHAT WE'RE DOING
TONIGHT?
>> WOW.
>> THE STARTERS NOT NAMED LeBRON
JAMES SCORED 11 POINTS IN GAME
FIVE.
THAT WON'T HAPPEN IN GAME SIX.
BRON DOESN'T NEED TO SCORE A
TRIPLE-DOUBLE TONIGHT, BUT HE'S
GOING TO NEED KUZMA, KCP, IF HE
CAN GO.
WE KNOW HE HAS A SORE LEFT KNEE.
ANDRE DRUMMOND.
WE NEED THOSE GUYS -- NOT WE,
BUT THE LAKERS NEED THOSE GUYS
TO SCORE IN DOUBLE DIGITS.
ON THE STRENGTH OF THAT AND
EVERY DUDE LOOKING IN THE MIRROR
TONIGHT, I THINK WE HAVE THE
LAKERS PUSHING THE SERIES TO
SEVEN GAMES.
THEY WON'T BE ELIMINATED
TONIGHT.
ROLE PLAYERS ARE THE KEY AND
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE A MUCH
BETTER PERFORMANCE THAN THEY DID
MANY GAME FIVE.
LAKERS IN GAME SIX.
G. MONEY, WHICH WAY YOU LEANING?
I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU ARE BLASTING
THE KING LIKE THAT SAYING HE
WON'T WIN ANOTHER TITLE IN HIS
CAREER.
ANY WAY, TONIGHT, WHICH WAY ARE
YOU LEANING?
SUNS OR LAKERS?
>> CABBIE, LET ME GET INTO THESE
COMMENTS.
THE PEOPLE ARE HERE BECAUSE THEY
WANT HOODIES AND THEY ALSO WANT
JERSEYS THAT I'M GIVING AWAY
LATER.
I'M GIVING AWAY MORE LATER.
RIGHT NOW I'M IN THE COMMENTS
GIVING AWAY HOODIES.
I SEE KING OF SPORTS 21 SAYS AS
THAT BOY GREG WOULD SAY ON
WINNERS ONLY WEDNESDAY, NOT
TODAY.
LAKERS ARE NOT GETTING
ELIMINATED.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
MAKE SURE YOU TAP BACK IN NEXT
WEDNESDAY ON WINNERS ONLY
WEDNESDAY ON B/R BETTING.
FOR THE CHIPS SAYS BOO.
SHE'S A LAKER HATER.
BAD VIBES.
ERIN IS NOT A LAKER HATER, BUT
WE'LL STILL GIVE YOU A HOODIE.
>> I HAD LeBRON WINNING LAST
GAME.
IT DID NOT GO WELL FOR ME.
>> ERIN, IT'S OKAY.
IT'S THE COMMENTS.
IT'S OKAY.
WE'LL GIVE THEM A HOODIE ANY
WAY.
ONE MORE FOR YOU.
I GOT NOT RONALD ACUNA JR., HE
SAYS IF A.D. DOESN'T PLAY,
GOOD-BYE LAKERS.
I ENDED ON THAT COMMENT FOR A
REASON.
THAT'S HOW I FEEL.
I FEEL LIKE IF A.D. PLAYS, I
FEEL THE LAKERS ARE GOING TO
STRETCH THIS SERIES INTO A
SEVEN-GAME SERIES.
IF HE DOES NOT PLAY, THE LAKERS
MIGHT BE PACKING THEIR BAGS AND
HEADING TO CANCUN SOON.
A.D. IS LISTED AS QUESTIONABLE.
IT'S GAME SIX.
THEIR BACKS ARE UP AGAINST THE
WALL.
I'M LEANING TOWARDS HIM PLAYING
AND WITH THAT BEING SAID, I
THINK THE LAKERS WILL TAKE THIS
TO SEVEN.
>> SO YOU BELIEVE THAT A.D.'S
PLAYING TONIGHT, HE HAS A GROIN
INJURY.
HE HAS A HYPEREXTENDED KNEE.
HE'S GOT --
>> HE'S LISTED AS QUESTIONABLE.
>> I THINK THE LAKERS ARE
WINNING TONIGHT, TOO.
I DON'T KNOW WHY I'M BRINGING
THOSE VIBES INTO OUR GROUP CHAT.
>> HE'S STILL LISTED AS
QUESTIONABLE.
IT'S STILL UP IN THE AIR.
WE'LL SEE.
>> NOT SINCE THE PLAY-IN GAME
AGAINST THE WARRIORS ABOUT TWO
WEEKS AGO HAVE THE LAKERS FELT
THIS MUCH HEAT.
TODAY IN THE APP WE ASKED YOU
HOW MANY POINTS DO YOU THINK
THAT LeBRON JAMES DROPS TONIGHT?
THE LINE IS HIGH, FOLKS.
IT'S 31 1/2.
GREG, WHAT DO PEOPLE HAVE TO DO
TO TAKE A JERSEY HOME TONIGHT?
THAT'S THE GRAPHIC, BRON OVER OR
UNDER.
YOU SAW THE LINE.
31 1/2.
>> I WILL TELL THE PEOPLE WHAT
THEY NEED TO DO.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME
HOW MANY POINTS LeBRON JAMES IS
PUTTING UP TONIGHT.
I'M GOING TO GIVE AWAY A JERSEY
THIS TIME.
THIS IS THE JERSEY GIVEAWAY.
YOU GUYS FILL THOSE COMMENTS UP.
ERIN, ARE YOU ON THE OVER OR ARE
YOU ON THE UNDER?
>> NEVER FUN TO TAKE THE UNDER
BUT LeBRON 31 1/2?
ABSOLUTELY NOT IN THIS SERIES
HE'S AVERAGING 22 POINTS.
INSIDE THE STAPLES CENTER HE'S
AVERAGING 23.
I WILL SAY LeBRON WILL GO OFF,
YOU GUYS FEEL THAT, BUT GIVEN
THAT NAGGING ANKLE INJURY, I'LL
HAVE TO TAKE THE UNDER ON THIS
ONE.
>> I'M WITH YOU.
I'M TAKING THE UNDER AS WELL.
HE HAS THE ABILITY TO GO OFF,
BUT TONIGHT IS ABOUT THE ROLE
PLAYERS.
TREZ, DENNIS, MARQUISE MORRIS,
BEN McLEMORE, THOSE GUYS ARE
LOOKING FOR NEW CONTRACTS THIS
YEAR.
YOU KNOW TONIGHT THEY NEED TO
SHOW UP AND MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
THE LAST TIME BRON EVEN TOUCHED
30 POINTS WAS ON MARCH 18th.
LIKE TEN WEEKS AGO.
HE HAS THE CAPABILITY TO GET
THERE.
I DON'T THINK HE'LL GET THERE
TONIGHT.
I'M TAKING THE UNDER.
HE CAN GET 27, 28 POINTS.
OVER 31 1/2, NAH.
>> WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING FOR
THE KINGS?
OVER OR UNDER 31 1/2.
>> CABBIE, LET ME GET INTO THE
COMMENTS.
LET ME GET INTO THE COMMENTS AND
GIVE AWAY A HOODIE AND A JERSEY
THIS ROUND.
THEN I'LL GIVE YOU MY PICK.
ONCE AGAIN, THIS IS THE HANDY
DANDY iPHONE.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I GOT CHRIS NUNION 48 SAYING
LeBRON WILL BE ELIMINATED
TONIGHT.
I GUESS HE'S SAYING LeBRON IS
NOT SCORING OVER THE POINT
TOTAL.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I ALSO HAVE BUD SMOKEA SAYING
LeBRON JAMES IS GOING OVER.
ROCKING WITH LeBRON JAMES GOING
OVER.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
A IMDONE IN THE COMMENTS.
ACTUALLY, I NEED TO GIVE AWAY A
JERSEY.
NEXT PERSON I SAY, YOU'RE
WALKING AWAY WITH A JERSEY.
BROWNS FAN 94.
OLD SCHOOL LeBRON JAMES SHOWING
UP TONIGHT.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU BROWNS FAN 94,
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I'LL KEEP THIS SIMPLE AND SWEET.
I THINK LAIMS IS GOING TO GO
UNDER TONIGHT BECAUSE HE'S GOING
TO BE GETTING HIS TEAMMATES
INVOLVED TONIGHT.
WE'VE SEEN THIS TIME AFTER TIME.
LeBRON JAMES IN BIG GAMES, WE
WANT TO SEE HIM TAKE OVER THE
GAME, SCORING ALL THE POINTS.
SOME GAMES HE DID.
I CAN TRACE BACK TO THOSE
WARRIORS GAMES IN 2016.
LeBRON JAMES WAS BALLING.
HE WAS BALLING.
BUT TONIGHT, CABBIE, I THINK
HE'S GOING TO GET THE 25, BUT
HE'S ALSO GOING TO BE MAKING
SURE, LIKE YOU SAID EARLIER, THE
OTHER PLAYERS, HIS TEAMMATES, HE
HAS TO GET THEM INVOLVED.
HE'LL MAKE SURE THEY'RE INVOLVED
IN THIS ONE.
>> OTHER DUDES NEED TO EAT FOR
SURE.
BRON CAN EAT, BUT HE HAS TO GET
OTHER DUDES TO THE TABLE.
EVERYBODY IS CRUSHING THESE
PLAYER PERFORMANCE DOUBLES THIS
WEEK.
SQUAD LEGEND 4K MANAGEMENT HIT
THIS PERFORMANCE DOUBLES PARLAY.
IT WAS A CHEF KISS.
85-1.
100 BUCKS.
ALMOST 8,500.
THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
IT INSPIRED US TO LOOK AT SOME
PERFORMANCE DOUBLES OF OUR OWN.
THESE ARE THE PROPS AVAILABLE
FOR LeBRON JAMES.
ERIN, HOW SHOULD WE THINK ABOUT
BETTING PLAYER PERFORMANCE
DOUBLES?
IF YOU THINK LeBRON WILL PUT UP
OVER 35, ARE YOU BASICALLY
BETTING HALF A GAME FOR FREE
BY -- SORRY, ARE YOU BETTING A
FREE HALF GAME BY ADDING THE WIN
TO YOUR TICKET?
>> YEAH.
THESE ARE OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING
THAT BETTORS SHOULD TAKE VAN
E
ANTIBODY OF.
IN THIS MARKET YOU SAW ON THE
SCREEN, THE LAKERS TO WIN PLUS
PLAYER PERFORMANCE OF LeBRON.
IF YOU THINK HE'S GOING TO GO
OFF IN ASSISTS OR REBOUNDS, THIS
IS PERFECT.
IF YOU PAIR THAT WITH THE
LAKERS, YOU ARE GETTING SUCH
BETTER ODDS.
WE LOVE ANYTHING WITH PLUS
MONEY.
>> YES.
YES.
PLUS MONEY.
LOVE IT.
LOVE THE PLUS MONEY.
CABBIE, WHICH WAY --
>> ARE WE IN?
ARE WE GIVING AWAY JERSEYS OR
HOODIES HERE?
>> OH.
OH.
YEAH.
LET ME THINK ABOUT IT.
LET'S GIVE AWAY SOME HOODIES
HERE.
>> LET'S DO IT.
>> BUT WAIT.
MY -- I GOT THE LAST JERSEYS
COMING UP NEXT ROUND.
LAST JERSEYS COMING UP NEXT
ROUND.
YOU GUYS HERE, GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHICH
PERFORMANCE DOUBLE IS A LOCK?
ERIN, WHICH WAY ARE YOU
LEANING?
WHICH WAY ARE YOU THINKING WITH
THIS PERFORMANCE DOUBLE?
>> I WILL GO LeBRON
DOUBLE-DOUBLE AND THE LAKERS TO
WIN, PLUS 162.
LeBRON HAD 45 DOUBLE-DOUBLES
THIS SEASON.
LeBRON IS AVERAGING 8 ASSISTS, 7
REBOUNDS THIS SEASON.
IF YOU WANT TO TAKE A SHOT AT
THE 10 PLUS REBOUNDS AND ASS
ASSISTS, GREAT VALUE.
BUT I'LL GO LeBRON JAMES
DOUBLE-DOUBLE AND THE LAKERS TO
WIN.
>> THAT'S THE SHOT I'M TAKING.
10 PLUS ASSISTS.
I JUST WISH HIM AND ANDRE
DRUMMOND COULD JUST RIM RUN.
PICK AND ROLL TO THE RIM.
GET CARUSO INVOLVED.
FIND THE SHOOTERS ON THE
PERIMETER.
I LIKE BRON TEN PLUS ASSISTS AND
THE LAKERS WIN.
COUPLE THOSE TOGETHER.
GET HIS TEAMMATES EARLY ON.
THE WAY THAT MICHAEL AND KOBE
USED TO, AND THEN DOMINATE IN
THE FOURTH QUARTER.
TAKE THE GAME OVER.
WE KNOW YOU'RE NOT 100 BR%.
YOU SAID IT.
WE SAW IT ON THE SHOP.
GET YOUR TEAMMATES INVOLVED
EARLY.
TEN ASSISTS.
IF HIS TEAMMATES ARE MAKING
SHOTS, TEN ASSISTS ARE WITHIN
SIGHT.
LOCK THAT IN.
G. MONEY, WHICH PERFORMANCE
DOUBLE DO YOU LIKE TONIGHT FOR
LeBRON JAMES?
>> LET ME GET INTO THESE
COMMENTS REALLY QUICK.
GIVE AWAY SOME HOODIES.
THIS IS WHAT THE PEOPLE ARE HERE
FOR.
THEY WANT HOODIES AND JERSEYS.
SO I GOT NOT ZACK LEVINE SAYING
THE DOUBLE-DOUBLE TO HIT MORE
THAN THREE POINTERS IS A LOT.
I GUESS HE'S SAYING THE
DOUBLE-DOUBLE AND THE THREE
POINTERS IS A LOT.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
>> YEAH.
>> HE'S WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
DOWN TO EARTH SAYS THE ONLY ONE
YOU CAN TAKE IS PLUS THREE
THREES.
HE THINKS LeBRON IS ABOUT TO
HAVE A STEPH CURRY PERFORMANCE
TONIGHT.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
HITMAN ZAZA SAYS LeBRON, TEN
PLUS ASSISTS AND THE WIN.
I'LL STOP THERE.
THAT'S WHAT I'M ROCKING WITH.
LEBRON TEN PLUS ASSISTS AND A
WIN.
WE JUST GOT DONE TALKING ABOUT
IT.
LeBRON WON'T GO OVER HIS POINT
TOTAL.
WHY?
HE WILL GET HIS TEAMMATES
INVOLVED.
WE'RE CONNECTING THE DOTS HERE.
MAKING IT MAKE SENSE.
LeBRON, OVER TEN ASSISTS AND A
WIN.
>> I LIKE THAT ONE PERSON'S
HANDLE, NOT ZACK LEVINE.
NONE OF US ARE.
ONLY ZACK LEVINE IS ZACK LEVINE.
FOLKS HAVE BEEN OUT HERE HITTING
ALL KINDS OF LONG SHOTS ON THESE
FIRST BASKET PARLAYS.
THAT ADRENALINE RUSH FROM THE
TIP HAS TO BE OTHER WORLDLY.
SALUTE TO THOSE TAKING BIG
SWINGS LIKE JEREL REYES.
HE TURNED $4 INTO ALMOST 3,000.
THAT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
HE EVEN HAS A FEW DOUBLES
SPRINKLED IN THERE.
THAT INSPIRED US TO BUILD OUR
FIRST BASKET PARLAY FOR
TONIGHT'S DOUBLEHEADER.
DENVER AND PORTLAND, PHOENIX AND
L.A.
LET'S LOOK AT THE ODDS FOR THE
FIRST GAME.
DENVER AND PORTLAND.
FIRST BASKET PROPS.
THESE ARE ALL JUICY.
SO THIS IS THE SECOND GAME,
PHOENIX AND L.A.
LET'S LOOK AT THE FIRST GAME ON
TNT TONIGHT WITH DENVER AND
PORTLAND.
I LIKE THAT.
THAT'S A LONG SHOT.
I DON'T THINK I HAVE THE GUTS TO
TAKE IT.
THESE ODDS ARE SO JUICY.
SO HARD TO HIT.
G. MONEY, IS IT FINALLY JERSEY
TIME?
ARE WE JUMPING INTO THE FIRST
BASKET PARLAYS?
>> CABBIE, IT'S JERSEY TIME.
ONE JERSEY TO GIVE OUT.
>> IS THAT AN OFFICIAL SONG?
>> THAT'S FROM THE JERSEY SHORE,
RIGHT?
>> ERIN KNOWS.
>> I LIVE RIGHT BY THERE.
THAT'S WHY I KNOW THAT.
♪
>> I NEED EVERYBODY TO GET IN
THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHO IS
A LOCK TO HIT A FIRST BASKET
TONIGHT.
ERIN, GIVE IT TO ME.
WHO DO YOU THINK?
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING?
WHO DO YOU THINK IS HITTING THE
FIRST BASKET TONIGHT?
>> THESE ARE YOUAWESOME.
SO JUICY.
MICHAEL PORTER JR. AND DeANDRE.
I FEEL LIKE YOU SHOULD GO WITH
THE LONG SHOTS.
THESE ARE BOTH AT PLUS 750.
YOU MIGHT AS WELL TRY TO GET AS
MUCH VALUE AS YOU CAN FOR THE
BIRTH BASKET SCORE.
>> CAN WE PULL UP PORTLAND AND
DENVER AGAIN?
I WAS THINKING -- I WAS GOING TO
GO WITH THE BIG MAN DOWN THERE.
I'M GOING TO PLAY IT SAFE WITH
CHRISTIAN JAMES McCULLOM.
DIDN'T HAVE A GREAT GAME IN GAME
FIVE WHEN DAMIAN LILLARD SET THE
BASKETBALL WORLD ON FIRE WITH 12
THREE-POINTERS, BUT McCULLOM,
JUST GET IT STARTED WITH A
LITTLE LANE OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
I LIKE THAT.
AND IN THE SECOND GAME, DENNIS
WAS 0 FOR 9 IN THE GAME.
WE KNOW FOR SURE HE NEEDS A
REDEMPTION GAME.
THAT STARTS TONIGHT.
FIRST BASKET.
CJ McCOLLUM AND DENNIS AS MY
PARLAY.
G. MONEY, WHICH PLAYERS ARE YOU
PARLAYING FOR THE FIRST BASKET?
>> THIS IS A TOUGH ONE.
THIS IS A TOUGH ONE.
I'M GOING TO GO WITH DAMIAN
LILLARD AND DRUMMOND.
GIVE ME DRUMMOND.
I THINK DAME WAS HOT LAST GAME.
I DON'T THINK ANYTHING WILL
CHANGE.
>> THE DUDE WAS SCORCHING.
HOT IS AN UNDERSTATEMENT.
>> I THINK HE WAS GOING TO COME
OUT FIRING.
THEN I ALSO THINK DRUMMOND.
YOU TALKED ABOUT IT.
THEY NEED TO GET HIM GOING.
THEY NEED TO GET HIM IN THE FLOW
OF THE OFFENSE.
SO I THINK EARLY ON LeBRON WILL
BE LOOKING FOR HIM TO GET HIM
INVOLVED.
HE WILL SCORE THE FIRST BASKET.
GUESS WHAT, GUYS?
I'M GIVING AWAY A HOODIE AND A
JERSEY BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE IT.
>> OKAY.
>> I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT
NOW.
GIVING AWAY HOODIES AND A JE
Y
JERSEY.
I HAVE MEECH NORRIS GIVING US
GIFS IN THE COMMENTS.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I GOT JOE YAN IN THE COMMENTS
WITH THE GAME TIME GIF.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
HOODIE.
AK47, YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
CABBIE, DO YOU THINK IT'S TIME
TO GIVE AWAY A JERSEY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
PUT A SMILE ON SOMEBODY'S FACE
TONIGHT.
THEY'RE PROBABLY GOING TO HIT
THEIR BETS, BUT WHY NOT GIFT
THEM A JERSEY AS WELL, MY DUDE.
GOOD VIBES.
>> WE WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT
"JERSEY SHORE."
SO I GOT SOMEBODY IN HERE WITH
THE USER NAME OF JERSEY PLEASE.
SAYS RIDE LILLARD TO THE MOON.
JERSEY PLEASE.
I GUESS THEY -- I DON'T KNOW.
JERSEY PLEASE, THEY SAID RIDE
LILLARD TO THE MOON.
GUESS WHAT?
I'M DELIVERING -- I WAS GOING TO
SAY I'M RIDING YOU A T-SHIRT.
I'M NOT DOING THAT.
I'LL GIVE YOU A JERSEY.
I'LL SEND YOU $125 TO GET YOU A
JERSEY.
YEAH.
WE'RE ALSO ROCKING WITH DAME
LILLARD, AS YOU SAW.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO GET THE
FIRST BASKET.
>> PERFECT PUNCTUATION.
WHEN IT'S GAME TIME, IT'S DAME
TIME.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US ON "THE
GROUP CHAT" PRESENTED BY
FANDUEL.
THE SQUAD KNOWS BRON IS IN
TROUBLE TONIGHT.
TROUBLE, TROUBLE, TROUBLE.
GET ON FANDUEL AND BET YOUR
FAVORITE FIRST BASKET PARLAY AND
COME BACK NEXT THURSDAY FOR MORE
HOODIES AND JERSEYS.
ALONGSIDE ERIN DOLAN AND GREG
IVORY, I'M CABBIE RICHARDS.
WE'RE LEAVING THE GROUP CHAT.
PEACE.
♪